the tri-color fluttering high it was
first hoisted here in 1947 when British
rule ended 75 years later prime minister
Narendra Modi honored Freedom Fighters
and pledged to turn India into a
developed nation
in 25 years India will celebrate 100
Years of Independence many of you will
be 50 years old dedicate these years to
helping your country reach its true
potential
the Triumph of Independence came with
the horrors of partition riots broke out
in both India and Pakistan killing at
least a million people decades later
many are trying to find Common Ground
mahalakshmi soda grew up in Sindh and
now lives in balrampur her family are
among the many Hindus who stayed in
Pakistan she says she feels lucky to
live in both countries my family stands
out because you know people feel that
people were hostile towards us and no
they weren't and what our family's
history was my great I'm proud that my
great grandfather took that decision and
where it comes like I'm married what is
the difference actually because we are
married in a rajput again Australian
family of balrampur so our culture and
everything is very similar so it was not
a big change for me as part of the
celebrations the government has asking
people to fly the tri-color celebrities
have joined the campaign and Traders say
the response has been unprecedented the
flag was one of the major symbols of the
independence movement the government
says it wants people to build personal
connections with the tri-color to invoke
patriotism
some analysts see this as a way to
redefine nationhood and its violent past
I ask myself is it the case that the
flag is also representing to us uh
a kind of reliving of that very
traumatic violent time
is it the case that we are actually
remembering an antagonism that was
extremely divisive extremely violent and
the reason for partition
critics say religious tensions have
increased under Narendra Modi but on
Independence Day Indians from all walks
of life turned out to celebrate Al
Jazeera New Delhi
well I'm pleased to say we have Shashi
tharo an MP from India's opposition
congress party joins us live now from
New Delhi sir welcome to the program
India of course a very different country
from that of 75 years ago it's the
world's fifth largest economy literacy
rates have soared life expectancy is
radically better but there are still
entrenched challenges how do you look to
the Future now on this day
well I think that the the future can be
very very promising because uh you
mentioned all the right things we've
gone from A literacy rate of 16 to 82
we've gone from 90 percent of the
population living below the poverty line
in 1947 to about 20. we've gone from uh
life expectancy of 27 to over 70. so
then all of this is good and at the same
time because of the scale of the country
and the the nature of the challenges
before us we know it's not enough
there's a lot more that needs to be
accomplished and I think that's that's
fundamental but there are some things
that the government is doing right even
if I'm in the opposition I would say
that the emphasis that's been given on
technology could actually be quite a
game changer for India for in the
India's economy and for India's role of
the world
um the government has just announced
that the Indian holy indigenous 5G
technology is capable of taking on the
world and that's something where we're
looking forward to seeing
um I think that the overall perception
of the economy is relatively bullish
what worries people like me is the onset
of a divisive uh social agenda on the
part of the ruling party and its
supporters which needlessly is provoking
a sense of division and therefore
alienation amongst our minorities and
particularly the Muslim minority yeah
sexual challenges that you refer to are
immense aren't they and not at least the
religious nature and makeup of the
country so how
how would you take that on
well I can tell you how we did take it
all we've had very different governments
after 2014 and they went out of their
way to instill a
added of coexistence and Harmony of
acceptance and difference
um some have described that in the
ruling circles I've described that as
appeasement but you know uh it certainly
kept social peace and Harmony and they
would rightly I think boast with pride
that with 180 million Muslims in this
country barely a handful of Muslims ever
went into Taliban or Al-Qaeda or Isis or
any of those extremist organizations
because these are people who believe
they have a stake in this society and so
no reason to do it harm I think
depriving people of a sense of of that
kind of affinity and belonging could be
very dangerous and I certainly hope the
government either clamps down on the
hotheads who are behaving badly uh or or
pulls them back if some of them have had
government because I think the
government doesn't need that to stay in
power judging by their continued habits
of winning elections right and at the
same time at the same time we in the
opposition
um have this very important issue to
keep beating them on the head with they
may as well give it up like many nations
around the world the richest 10 control
most of the wealth and for the poor of
India that's a tough reality isn't it
yes I mean there is no question that
inequality is extremely great that's
probably been getting more uh unequal
with the passage of time but I will say
that if you were to look objectively
we've managed for some time at least
when we were in government for
government for 10 years to ensure that
while the rich got richer the poor got a
bit richer too in fact we averaged about
10 million people rising above the
poverty line during each of our 10 years
in governance and that's near a small
feat that's 100 million people who are
no longer officially put I'm sorry to
say that a lot of those people have
slipped back below the poverty line in
recent years but also that perhaps the
the pace of change has been affected by
factors like the covert pandemic and the
associated lockdown the government
self-inflicted rule of demonetizing
large chunks of our currency and so on
so there there have been some some
mismanagements as well but at the end of
the day it can be done that yes you do
have growth and with to get richer
people getting even richer still but you
can ensure that the poor benefit as well
and they also rise employment for
example is going to be key if you can
actually ensure jobs for more people out
of the growing economy rather than
jobless growth then you have a situation
in which you will be able to transform
India for the better okay
appreciate your analysis and your
perspective that Shashi thorough MP from
India's opposition congress party thank
you
thank you very much